hello and welcome to footnotes as usual
I'm here to recap the most ravishing
language and ideas from the last week of
Wired first up today I'm drunk no not
but I would be if I drank all the drinks
in Wired businesses gallery of tech
companies as alcoholic beverages I
wanted to talk about a few of these
drinks and I'll start with Groupon as
PBR they're similar because you should
never invest in either of them beer was
most likely the first booze invented by
humans and that first batch no doubt
tasted better than PBR and it probably
happened by accident but like you're
much younger brother this was a good
kind of accident one theory holds that
thousands of years ago some guy who did
not know he was a genius collected
grains in a jar put it down and forgot
about it it rained and natural yeast in
the air got into the mix because yeast
is nosy like that the fella eventually
came back and found beer and a leap of
faith he drank it and spent the trip
back to the village telling his friend
they thought the guy's wife was very
attractive but that he totally respected
their marriage then he fell over next up
apple as absinthe not because both are
green and loved by French people but
because both supposedly turn folks into
menacing addicts you see absinthe was
once thought to not only be more
addictive than other spirits but to also
cause hallucinations so it was widely
band at the turn of the 20th century
because heaven forbid the people trip
every once in a while and write a bad
poem or two the problem is absinthe
isn't any more addictive than other
spirits and the supposedly
hallucinogenic chemical called thujone
isn't anything such the real issue is
absinthe can be up to 75 percent alcohol
so if you drink enough of it you're
going to see things lots of things
sometimes two of each sometimes dozens
of each if you happen to get a hold of a
kaleidoscope the irrational ban on
absinthe was lifted in the u.s. in 2007
without so much as an insincere apology
but luckily we've always had bourbon and
it's the bourbon and you who cocktail
that is most likely ahoo because you
wouldn't want your friends seen you use
either of them bourbon takes its name
from its birthplace Bourbon County
Kentucky it was here where distillers
fled in the 1790s to escape a new tax on
whiskey in this sense they were like
hard drinking nine rands only probably
more literate so while the Scots use
peat a sort of bog matter to give their
whiskies a smoky flavor American bourbon
Maker's use Kentucky's unique limestone
ridge water to craft a one-of-a-kind
spirit thus we have a distinctly
American liquor which like the very
first booze is great for getting drunk
and telling our friends were attracted
to their spouses then we Americans fall
over hurt ourselves and if we don't have
insurance get less health care than the
first drunks with the very least had pro
bono which doctors
you